♪♪
The show, TEHRAN, is very
exciting.
♪♪
Engage. Engage!
Niv:
It's about an Israeli secret
agent...
...on a mission, undercover in
Iran.
♪♪
Her sole job is to plant a
virus...
Daniel:
in Tehran's anti-aircraft
defense.
♪♪
Moshe:
She's cool. She's smart.
And she will do anything to
succeed in her mission.
Which is very dangerous.
You have forty seven minutes, you will
be home by tomorrow afternoon.
Alright.
Very fast, everything goes
wrong.
♪♪
And now she is stuck in Tehran,
running for her life.
♪♪
But she never gives up, she
never quits.
♪♪
Niv:
She keeps trying to fill her
mission.
In many kinds of ways.
♪♪
(Bam)
She's a badass girl.
♪♪
The cops are here, you have to
get out.
Tamar:
We're not gonna get another
chance.
The show has amazing action.
♪♪
Tamar:
I need your help.
Let's go.
♪♪
We start asking ourself: who is
the good guy and...
who's the bad guy?
♪♪
Daniel:
And you want to know the end of
the story.
♪♪
Take her out of there tonight!